just pour has started with today's video
I want to thank brilliant for sponsoring
it to support by graphics and learn more
about brilliant go to brilliant org
slash by graphics and sign up for free
[Music]
galileo galilei was a truth seeker his
quest for truth though was to bring him
into conflict with the most powerful
institution of his day the Roman
Catholic Church through such inventions
as the telescope he revealed truths that
landed him in front of the Holy Roman
Inquisition fighting for his very
survival condemned during his life he
has now revered as a true genius in
today's by graphics we're getting the
full story on Galileo Galilei
Galileo Galilei was born on February the
15th 1564 in Pisa Italy he was the first
of six children to vincenzo de Bono
jutted Galilei and Giller Galilee the
Galileans and respected family who
originated in Florence vincenzo was a
wool trader who had an abiding interest
in philosophy science and music at the
age of four days young Galileo was
baptized Catholic he was raised
according to the strict tenets of the
faith as was everybody else in the
region from an early age Galileo showed
an intense interest in making things he
was constantly making small little
gadgets that would amuse his friends and
his teachers these would include wooden
animals with moving arms and legs he was
fascinated by how machines worked and be
constantly pulling things apart and then
putting them back together again if he
was making a machine himself and he
didn't have a part he simply improvised
when Galileo was 10 years of age his
father decided to move the family to
Florence by now Vincenzo had developed a
reputation as a learned and wise man
despite the demands of business he
managed to write several books the most
popular of which was the dialog of
ancient and modern music wealthy people
streamed to him to benefit from his
knowledge of Greek and Roman literature
and sir here his musical theories he was
invited to spend some time with Duke
Albrecht of Bavaria who lived in Munich
Germany some 300 miles from Florence
Vincenzo was also an active member of
the Florentine Camerata
this were a group of musicians who were
experimenting with musical drama and now
as the genesis of what would become
opera Galileo knew siblings were
therefore raised in an intellectually
stimulating environment
Vincenzo taught his oldest son how to
play a number of musical instruments the
favorite of which for both was the lute
Galileo
also experimented with drawing and
painting and showed great promise in
both of these areas his teenage years
they coincided with the high Renaissance
period when Italy was being filled with
the works of the great painters
sculptors and architects he considered
devoting his life to that of an artist
but as father was keen for his son to
follow him into the wool trade vincenzo
he had a great passion for the arts but
he knew that nothing but a solid
business
career would secure a stable financial
future for his son by the time the
Galileo had reached his mid-teens it was
apparent to everyone including his
father that his keen mind was destined
for greater things than life as a wool
trader vincenzo saw it his duty to
encourage Galileo to use his god-given
intellectual talents to the fullest
extent through his studies if the works
of Aristotle vincenzo had instilled in
his son the discipline of independent
study of observation and experimentation
rather than being swayed by what others
had already concluded on a matter he
would independently study the subject
for himself and reach his own
conclusions based on those observations
when he was 15 years of age Galileo
attended the Benedictine monastery of
Santa Maria de Ville ambrosa from the
monks he learned religion and logic
after a few months however he had to
return home because he got an eye
infection when he was 17 Galileo passed
the bachelors exam which permitted him
entry to the University of Pisa
universities in the 16th century there
were places attended by members of only
the wealthiest families and were
generally reserved for those with the
ambition of becoming a priest a doctor
or a professor
although Galileo seriously considered
the priesthood as a young man Galileo or
more likely Galileo's father had decided
on a career in medicine for him in order
to achieve it he first had to obtain a
master's degree Galileo
applied himself to his studies and made
excellent progress however several
months into the first year of his
medical degree he happens over here a
geometry lecture being delivered by a
friend of his father Asti Leo Ritchie he
was immediately attracted to the logic
and beauty of the math that was being
applied when Ricci heard from Galileo's
father that the boy was fascinated with
his lecture he invited him to take his
course
Vincenzo had first made Ritchie promise
not to let Galileo know that he had
consented to him taking the geometry
paper in case he saw it as permission to
abandon his medical studies in addition
to attending geometry lectures Galileo
worked one-on-one with Ritchie as he
studied the works of the Greek
mathematician Euclid
as he became more deeply immersed in the
subject Galileo became less interested
in medicine finally he confronted his
father and asked him not to stand in the
way of his focus on geometry Vincenzo
realist he knew that his son would not
prosper as a doctor if his heart wasn't
in it he agreed to support Galileo in
his mathematical pursuits after
switching to mathematics Galileo brought
his full intellectual rigor to bear on
the subject he was an excellent students
but he still managed to frustrate his
professors the inclination to question
everything that his father had instilled
in him meant that he would not accept
anything as fact established theories
they were meaningless unless he had
personally pulled them apart studied
them and reached his own conclusions it
was the Aristotle Ian's scientific
method in action but it even caused the
teenager to question the theories of
Aristotle himself one day when he was 19
galileo happened to be in the Pisa
Cathedral for a mass observance after
the service he was wandering around the
building when his attention happened to
be caught by a sculpted bronze lamp
located in the dome of the cathedral the
lamp was swinging back and forth like a
pendulum he observed that regardless of
the lessening arc of the swing the time
that it took for each swing remained the
same to check this observation he timed
the swings with his pulse this led him
to the realization that the rhythmic
swings of a pendulum were an excellent
way to measure the human pulse this was
the inspiration for the later invention
of Galileo's machine that was designed
to take pulses or a harmonic oscillator
this is the first example of Galileo not
only observing and testing phenomena but
also finding practical applications of
his findings
by 1585 the financial strain of
supporting his sons university studies
it was too much Vincenzo and Galileo had
to withdraw from the University of Pisa
he hadn't yet completed his doctoral
degree but the budding genius he was not
to be deterred he embarked upon his own
studies by examining the works of the
great minds of ancient Rome in ancient
Greece after dissecting the works of
Archimedes he wrote his first scientific
dissertation in which he describes an
invention that he called the little
balance this was a hydrostatic scale to
measure the air water balance he also
developed a horse powered pump for crop
irrigation that was inspired by the
famous Archimedes screw just as his
father had a decade earlier with his
muscle talent
Galileo began to impress important
people with his practical application of
science he gained a reputation as an
upcoming scientist one person who is
particularly interested in Galileo's
work was the Marquis guida Baldo de
menthe a wealthy patron with an abiding
interest in astronomy mathematics and
architecture Marquis began writing to
Galileo in the too maintained a vigorous
correspondence during which Galileo
would explain his latest observations
and applications de Monte encouraged the
22 year old Galileo to study the center
of gravity in solid bodies which altom
Utley led to the publication of a
treatise on the subject it was through
del Monte that Galileo came to the
attention of the Grand Duke of Tuscany
Ferdinand's the first de Medici in 1589
the Grand Duke pointed him as a
professor of mathematics at the
University of Pisa this was the position
that Galileo had been hoping to secure
ever since he had been forced to quit
his studies at the time mathematics was
a minor subject of study at university
that wasn't even seen as worthy of study
by many people Galileo's salary was only
60 florins a year while philosophy
professors they don't 600 or more in
addition he was looked down on by them
as a young upstart who dared to question
the teachings of the great Aristotle to
them this was akin to blasphemy with the
writings of Aristotle being considered
the final word on all things ironically
Galileo was simply following through on
the teachings of Aristotle himself who
championed independent study and
observation well aware that his own
theories could well be overturned
new knowledge was observed the most
famous example of Galileo not simply
accepting one of Aristotle's theories
because it was written down on paper
had to do with the speed of falling
objects Aristotle had contended that two
objects of different weights would fall
to the ground at different speeds with
the heaviest object falling faster as
the story goes Galileo he climbed to the
top of the Leaning Tower of Pisa
although the building thought to have
been used may have been the church tower
in Delft and then he dropped two spheres
of different masses to the ground below
they both hit the ground at the same
time disproving Aristotle's theory
Galileo's experiment at the Tower of
Pisa was believed to have been observed
by many of his students and fellow
professors of the University still some
of the professor's refused to
acknowledge that the young man had just
overturned one of our startles theories
this stubborn refusal to accept
empirical evidence that overturns long
entrenched views is something that
Galileo was going to contend with for
the rest of his life now just before we
continue with today's video it is rather
appropriately sponsored by brilliance
and learning platform so whether you
want to get to grips with more classical
stuff like Galileo ins is dropping
things or maybe something a bit more
recent like quantum computing or
brilliant is the place to do it now
you've heard me talk about brilliant
before they're a learning platform that
focuses on active learning this is where
you're given a short bit of information
on a specific scientific concept and
then you're asked you to solve a problem
based on that information
it's an incredibly effective way to
learn and right now brilliant have
actually got something relatively new on
their platform called daily problems
these are problems that you can do for
five minutes a day they exercise your
brain and they teach you something new
if you're into learning new things which
you probably are cuz you're watching
this channel brilliant is great for you
each problem it provides you the context
and the framework you need to tackle it
that means you can learn concepts by
applying them
that's that active learning stuff this
sort of short daily practice can lead
you from curiosity to mastery in far
less time than you would think so go to
brilliant dog /bi graphics and finish
your day a little smarter the first 200
of you to do so will get 20% off your
annual subscription and you'll be able
to view all of the problems in the
archives let's get back to Galileo
because start to make some enemies
not long after the tower experiment
Galileo was approached by a member of
the powerful Medici family Giovanni de
Medici and asked to evaluate a machine
that he had invented the machine was
designed to dredged the harbour bottoms
of Legon to remove the mucky layer and
make them safer for ships to come into
Galileo carefully studied the machine no
need to conclude that it was badly
designed and not fit for purpose this
presented a bit of a problem
should he be honest and tell the man
that the machine wouldn't work or should
he placate him with false praise the
Medicis were the most powerful clan in
Italy and Galileo was very wary of
getting on the wrong side of any of them
still his loyalty to scientific truth
would not allow him to deceive the
inventor in a public forum he spelled
out what was wrong with the Machine and
assured everyone present that it would
not work his opinion was borne out when
the machine proved to be a dismal
failure Galileo's honesty had created a
powerful enemy
the humiliated Medici man was determined
to bring Galileo down and he set about
getting him fired from his professorship
at the University under the advice of
Marquis guida Baldo de Monte Galileo he
resigned his position down once they had
opened the door to a new posting as the
chairman of mathematics at the
University of Padua a hundred and thirty
miles northeast of Pisa this was a big
step up for Galileo he was now making
180 florins which was three times his
previous income also he no longer had to
contend with the ridicule of his fellow
professors he soon became a very popular
lecturer with his classes almost
overflowing at Padua he also found the
time to work on his inventions and his
writings he became an expert at applying
science to military fortifications
designing reinforced walls for forts and
mechanically superior siege engines in
1593 he was invited to Venice to give
advice on the ideal positioning of a
rowing ship's oars to generate maximum
use of manpower in 1593
Galileo developed an undiagnosed illness
which kept him in pain affected his
appetite
and robbed him of sleep these symptoms
would affect him for the rest of his
life despite his sickness he managed to
meet his university obligations at the
end of his first six year term at Padua
he was appointed for a further six years
by the ends of the 1590s Galileo had
invented a range of products which were
in demand all over the country
these included an irrigation pump that
required only a single horse to power
and the sector which was used to measure
precise angles lacking the time to
produce each piece himself he hired a
craftsman named mark Antonio Mansell any
to make his inventions it wasn't until
the mid 15 90s the Galileo took any
serious interest in astronomy without
studying the issue he believes in the
Ptolemaic theory that the Sun and other
planets revolved around the earth when a
visiting lecturer spoke on the
Copernican theory which contended that
the earth and other planets actually
revolve around the Sun Galileo did not
attend considering the theory to be
ridiculous sometime later he was talking
with some of his students who had
attended the lecture most of them didn't
accept the new theory but there was one
person who did it was then that Galileo
had a simple but profound realization
every person who had abandoned the
Ptolemaic theory in favor of the
Copernican theory would be subjected to
ridicule they were therefore only do so
on the basis of overwhelming evidence he
was now obsessed with finding out what
that evidence was the question of
whether the Sun or the earth was at the
center of the universe would consume him
for the rest of his life even though he
continued to teach the theories of
Ptolemy in his classes he became more
convinced that Copernicus was actually
right in 1597 he established written
communication with the German astronomer
Johannes Kepler who was also an advocate
of the Copernican theory Kepler had
published a work supporting a panic as'
and encouraged Galileo to do the same
however the Italian he was worried that
doing so would bring upon him the anger
of the Catholic Church which held that
the earth was undoubtedly at the center
of the universe on a visit of Venice
Galileo met a woman by the name of
marina gamba a relationship developed
with marina moving in with him before
long a child was born to the unwed
couple the first of three two girls and
a boy in 1610 Galileo left Padua taking
his two daughters growth Givens at the
convent eventually due to their
illegitimate births but he left behind
his son Vincenzo with Marina years later
marina married another man but Galileo
remained friendly with her throughout
his lifetime
in the first decade of the 1600s Galileo
continued to invent new technologies in
1604 he observed and discussed Kepler's
supernova his talk was so popular that
he had to move from the overcrowded
lecture theatre to an outside forum so
that everyone could hear him in 1609
Galileo began working on a machine that
would magnify the night sky he used to I
glass lenses one concave and the other
convex placing them at opposite ends of
a long metal tube when looking through
this venetian glass later called a
telescope the stars were magnified
several times the invention was a hit
and prominent people from all over Italy
clambered to get a look at this amazing
machine which allowed you to see things
that are far away his telescopes they
were also a profitable sideline for
Galileo who sold them to merchants who
found them useful both at sea and as
items of trade the invention reflected
positively on the University of Padua
prompting the board to offer Galileo a
lifetime professorship and increases
salary to a thousand florins before long
Galileo had improved his telescope until
he was able to magnify up to 30 times
this enabled him to look through it of
the moon he discovered that rather than
being perfectly round and smooth as
Aristotle had written it was rough and
filled with craters and valleys his
telescope also enabled Galileo to
identify and observe the moons of other
planets during the period between
January the 8th and the 14th 1610 he
discovered that Jupiter had four moons
then in July of that same year he became
the first person to identify the rings
around Saturn though he didn't quite
realize what they were at the time later
that year he identified the Jupiter and
Mars had phases which were similar to
the moon through his telescope Galileo
was able to identify that there were
many many more stars than had originally
been thought and that therefore the
universe was simply much larger than
previously thought this upset many
people who thought that through his
telescope Galileo was using some form of
trickery to make new discoveries in 1609
he was invited to move to the palace of
the Grand Duke in Florence he accepted
moving back to his home region of
Tuscany his drop now involved giving
lectures to princes and other members of
the royal family no longer having to
lecture he now had the freedom to study
and write books
[Music]
by 16 15 there was a rising tide of
opposition to Galileo many of his
discoveries had flown in the face of
accepted church doctrine which was
closely aligned with the teachings of
Aristotle
people began asserting that his findings
were at odds with the Scriptures which
were the revealed Word of God
Galileo responded by writing that the
Bible was not a scientific textbook but
where it touched on science it was
actually in harmony with his findings he
thought that people had simply
interpreted the Scriptures incorrectly
the letter the Galileo wrote soon found
its way into the hands of his enemies
particularly the dominicans of some mark
they viewed what he had written as
heresy and they made sure that a copy of
the letter got in front of the Pope in
Rome the Pope called for the leading
Dominican to come and give testimony
about Galileo this man made the most of
the opportunity telling lies to paint
Galileo and his followers as blasphemous
Galileo he was not coward he considered
those who spoke against him as ignorant
fools and he set out to defend himself
to do so he traveled to the center of
the caldron itself Rome he appeared
before the Holy Office on February the
26th 1616 and was ordered to never again
teach that the Sun was the center of the
universe his reasoned arguments in his
defense fell on deaf ears Galileo
remained in rooms who argue with his
detractors this was not pleasing to his
patron back in the court of Tuscany he
felt that the conflicts could cause a
rift between them and Rome in June
Galileo
he finally complied returning to
Florence the stress of defending his
reputation it had taken a toll on
Galileo he was constantly plagued with
physical pain and spent increasing
amounts of time bedridden in 1617 he
moved to a hilltop villages outside of
Florence in order to benefit from the
rural air
he continued to study the heavens but
was now far more guarded about what he
wrote
then in 1618 his ailments worsened he
was confined to bed for several weeks
and he became extremely weak by 1624
there was a new pope urban the eighth as
a cardinal he had expressed admiration
for Galileo but he had never agreed with
the Copernican theory a slightly
recovered Galileo was convinced to make
a pilgrimage to Rome in order to meet
with the Pope in order to assess his
standing with the pontiff urban received
him well even presenting a medal and
promising a pension Galileo also noticed
that the church officials around Rome
were far less hostile to him
than they had been before he felt
confidence believing that the new pope
had eased the pressure on him in 1629
Galileo wrote a masterful work dialogue
concerning the two chief world's systems
which presented a dialogue between three
men on the merits of the Ptolemaic and
Copernican theories before it could be
published here to present is the chief
censor of the press in Rome he was
forced to make changes that presented
the Ptolemaic theory and a far more
favorable light and to state clearly
that the ideas expressed were not facts
but simply opinions
Galileo he made the changes but a series
of delays prevented the book's
publication until 1632
the new book brought out the ire of the
enemies of the now 68 year old Galileo
when Pope Urban got to read it he became
enraged he became convinced that one of
the three debaters in the book was based
on himself and he considered this to be
a insult of the highest level in August
of 1632 all copies of the book sold in
bookstores were seized and the printer
was ordered to cease publication then in
September Galileo was ordered to appear
before the Holy Roman Inquisition after
stalling due to ill health II finally
headed to Rome to face his inquisitors
on January the 20th 1633 he had to wait
until April the 12th to appear before
the Vice Commissioner of the Holy Office
and to other examiner's for preliminary
questioning it was stated that his book
was in direct violation of the 1616 oath
he had taken not to publicly discuss the
teachings of Copernicus in his defence
Galileo contended that the book was
simply a dialogue between the two
theories and did not favor the view that
the Sun was at the center of the
universe a second interview was held on
April the 30th this time Galileo was
more conciliatory agreeing that the
arguments in favor of the Copernican
theory come to the ear of the reader
with far greater force and power than
should have been imparted to them by
someone who regarded them as
inconclusive the interview concluded
with the examiners agreeing to give
Galileo time to prepare his full defence
that hearing was held on June the 21st
before he could fully develop his
defence he was asked point-blank whether
he had ever held to the Copernican
theory he answered that he had initially
been indifferent to both theories but
after careful study now believed in the
wisdom of the Ptolemaic theory this was
clearly not true and none of the
examiners believed him the following day
he was sentenced to prison with the term
to be decided later and his book was
banned
he was then made to read a statement of
apology on bended knee PO bourbon seemed
satisfied with this outcome Galileo had
then both condemned and humiliated the
Pope decided that the imprisonment to
which Galileo had been sentence could be
carried out by way of home detention
that's the Grand Duke of Tuscany is
villa near Rome however Galileo was
desperate to live out his last years in
Florence where his family were located
he wrote to the Pope begging his
indulgence which he was granted he would
be confined to the villa of a powerful
friends after five months he was
permitted to return to his own villa
[Music]
Galileo's final years were marked by ill
health by 1637 he was nearly totally
blind before his sight was gone
completely he managed to complete his
last and in his view his most
outstanding work entitled discourses and
mathematical demonstrations of two new
Sciences under the rules of his sentence
he could not publish it in Italy and so
the manuscript was smuggled to Amsterdam
and published there during his last day
as the blind genius received many
visitors to his villa he died on January
the 8th 1642 at the age of 77 he had
been fighting fever and heart problems
for months nearly a hundred years later
with his brilliance having finally been
recognized his remains were removed from
the chapel at Santa Croce and relocated
to a much more elaborate mausoleum
inside the church during this move three
fingers and a tooth were removed from
his remains one of these fingers the
middle finger from Galileo's right hand
is currently on exhibition at the Museo
Galileo in Florence Italy a monument was
also erected with a bust of Galileo and
two figures representing his monumental
achievements in the worlds of astronomy
and geometry so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week so hit that subscribe button I want
to click that bell as well so you find
out when we put out a new video also
please do check out brilliant they're a
fantastic sponsor letting us make longer
stuff like this so please click on them
in the link below and as always thank
you for watching
you
[Music]